if you were really looking forward to
the B5 reboot I might have some bad news
for you welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi
TV and movie channel
[Music]
as you know J Michael josinski recently
has been on Twitter talking about how he
was really pushing for a new series of
Babylon 5 a hard reboot from the ground
up completely redoing the series
creating a new series based on his
Original Classic idea now I am a massive
supporter of this I actually loved
Babylon 5. I think it would be really
interesting to see with modern CGI and
things watch Jay michaelski could do
with it but also I would just love the
idea of sort of comparing it to the
original and seeing what a more mature
JMS would do with the idea
but if you are a regular site tracker
you'll know that I do have a couple of
people I speak to that work in and
around the industry and the Rumor that's
coming out is that a decision is about
to be made on the Babylon 5 reboot and
it's not good news don't forget that if
you enjoy the content you can hit the
join button and become a fully fledged
side tracker that really helps out the
channel you can go to cygashtrack.com
there's loads of like merchandise things
on there and a load of new designs
coming very soon also if you are new to
the channel don't forget to like
subscribe and hit the Bell notification
so you miss none of our new videos as
well as the Sidetrack sides chat at the
moment it is looking like the CW Network
are going to pass on Babylon 5. now
there are a couple of reasons for this
firstly Mark pedowitz resigned on the
third of October just a week ago he was
the president of the CW and one of jms's
closest allies he was always been a
friend of the show and he was really the
driving force behind getting Babylon 5
back now he's been replaced by Dennis
Miller following next star of media
group's purchase of the CW now he seems
to have been ordered by nexstar to take
the CW into a slightly different
direction they're going to be moving
away from a lot of the superhero TV
series we're already seeing a lot of
them getting canceled and move more
towards sort of like reality TV and all
that crap that I'm never watching
cheap stuff to make that actually a lot
of people do watch they're going to make
it a very commercial Channel and that
seems to be the direction they want to
take it in the question that the CW and
the executives are asking is where does
Babylon 5 fit in with that
now I told you ages ago Warner Brothers
were interested in Babylon 5 but they
were maybe interested in putting it onto
the HBO Max network instead Babylon 5 is
currently actually on HBO Max the
original
and it's done very well people are
watching it
Warner Brothers look at that and go we
could do the same it's basically Warner
Brothers even though they make the show
and co-produce it with JMS have to wait
for the CW to make a decision before
they can say whether they want to or not
but the rumor that I'm hearing is even
though they would love Babylon 5 on the
HBO Max
they don't think the timing is right as
you may know Warner Brothers itself is
going through a massive restructure at
the moment and its parent company has
merged Warner Brothers with Discovery
Inc to create Warner Brothers Discovery
now hbr Max is going through a similarly
structure there's a new president in
charge etc etc they've been looking at
restructuring a lot of their upcoming
projects
um a complete creative redirection this
was the reason why Batgirl got canceled
not because it was particularly bad it
just doesn't fit in with the current
direction Warner Brothers want to go now
I know a lot of people have come out and
said that Warner Brothers have got
massive financial problems they don't I
mean it's actually shown by Matt Batgirl
that they don't have massive they were
quite happy to just scrape off 80
million dollars if they could have spent
just a little bit more finished off the
movie and put it on HBO Max and done
okay and maybe earn their money back but
they didn't even want to do that because
the film didn't fit with their I idea of
where they want Warner Brothers to go in
the future
now Babylon 5 could fit but the timing
just isn't right it's a little bit like
you know if you ever had that
relationship where you meet a girl that
you really like are you really fancy but
you've just come out of a long-term
relationship you're not really ready to
commit it's a little bit like that
um as a metaphor
Warner Brothers love Bible and five
Warner Brothers Love JMS they the timing
just isn't right they've got too much
else going on and they just can't put
the attention into a new committed
relationship
so what does that mean for Babylon 5
well from what I'm being told is the
decision has not been 100 definitely
made but this is the direction they're
leaning they could decide last minute
with some changes in negotiations to
pull the trigger and go with Babylon 5
anyway I asked what are the chances of
that and my source reckons maybe one in
five
so there's a four and five chance that
it's not going to happen but what are
the chances it could go on to HBO Max
he's my source says it's still very
possible they would love it too just not
right now
as the CW pause this project for a year
he could see HBO Max saying to JMS just
give us 12 months and then maybe we can
do something
but that is all speculation the first
decision is will this appear on the CW
it's not looking likely at the moment
but I have to also say that my source is
telling me that conversations have gone
in the direction and the Twitter storm
of a couple of weeks ago has been taken
notice of and both parties including
Warner Brothers are very aware of the
popularity of Babylon 5. even if this
doesn't happen right now I don't think
the project is dead I think it can
return and I think it will but maybe the
timing isn't quite right just now
so guys get in the comments and tell me
what you think of this news is it
disappointing or was you kind of
expecting it I have to admit I was
always 50 50 on whether this was going
to happen I was excited about it but I
always suspected it might not quite get
over the Finishing Line get in the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you are enjoying the content please
consider hitting that join button that
really supports the channel as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
thank you